.
IT IS SAD FOR THE KIDS AND JOE
NEEDS TO FIX THIS.
ANYWAY, SARA, THANK YOU.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS IS
REFUSING TO TRAVEL TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS SHE IS BUSY
DOING EVERY OTHER JOB THAT JOE
HANDS HER BECAUSE HE IS TOO BUSY
SLEEPING ALL DATE WITH A SIPPY
CUP.
SHE WON'T SEE FIRST-HAND THE
CRISIS.
SHE IS HEADED TO GUATEMALA FOR
HER FIRST FOREIGN TRIP AS VICE
PRESIDENT.
PROBABLY TRY TO TRY AND BRIBE
THESE COUNTRIES, TRY NOT TO LET
SO MANY PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER.
HERE WITH REACTION WITH A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT AS WELL, THE HOST
OF A BRAND-NEW SHOW HERE ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL, UNFILTERED
WITH DAN BOND GINO.
IT PREMIERES SATURDAY AT 10:00
P.M.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO CALL IT,
FILTERED DAN?
YOU DON'T KNOW ANY OTHERS.
YOU HAVE ONE SPEED AND IT
USUALLY GETS A LITTLE FASTER IF
YOU ARE UP AGAINST GERALDO.
AND IT CAN BECOME'S SPEED ON
STEROIDS.
GO AHEAD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> YEAH, THAT IS A GOOD WAY TO
SUM IT UP.
I WILL TAKE A TIP FROM YOU IN
THIS SHOW.
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW SEAN
CUDAHY CAN RARELY STICK TO THE
TELEPROMPTER.
I TOLD HIM KEPT GO LIGHT LIGHT
UP YOUR COFFEE.
I JUST WANT TO DO THE DAN
BONGINO THING.
>> Sean: NOBODY WOULD WATCH
TENSION FILTERED, SO IT HAS TO
BE UNFILTERED.
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS A DAN
BONGINO UNFILTERED.
>> Sean: DAN AND GERALDO HATE
EACH OTHER.
THEY DON'T HATE EACH OTHER.
THEY JUST GET A LITTLE HOT UNDER
THE COLOR.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> IT HAPPENS ON TV.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I WOULD NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
YOU HEARD SARA'S REPORT.
EASY THE HIGHS NUMBERS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY IN OVER 20 YEARS.
WE SEE THE PERILOUS JOURNEY KIDS
ARE TAKING A LOAN.
PUBLIC WE KNOW THAT IT IS OPEN
MARKET FOR THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS.
THIS IS AS BAD AS IT GETS AND IT
IS ALL CAUSED BY OPEN BORDERS
JOE.
WHAT DO WE DO?
>> YEAH, A COUPLE OF TAKEAWAYS
ON THIS.
ON THE COM A HARRISON KRANK
KNOWING HOW SHE WILL LEVERAGE
ANY POLITICAL OPPORTUNITY FOR A
PHOTO OP OR A SOUNDBITE.
YOU THINK SHE IS AVOIDING THE
BOARD UP EXCELLENT?
SHE IS AVOIDING THE BORDER
BECAUSE SHE KNOWS IT IS AN
APOCALYPTIC DISASTER.
IF SHE'S THOUGHT THIS WAS A
SUCCESS STORY, SHE WOULD BE DOWN
THERE TOMORROW WITH THE
WASHINGTON POST WITH A PHOTO OP
EN VOGUE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
SHE OF COURSE UNDERSTANDS THIS.
THE SECOND APPOINTMENT IS WHAT
IS REALLY FRUSTRATING ABOUT THIS
AT LISTENING TO SARA'S REPORTED
ON A VERY SERIOUS NOTE, MISSING
THIS MORNING TO FOX & FRIENDS, I
CONSUME CONTENT ON THIS
STATIONS, TOO.
I DON'T JUST WORK HERE.
I HEARD THE STORY THIS MONEY.
A WOMAN BEING RAPED ON THE
BORDER.
SHE GOT SHOT.
IT IS TOTAL ANARCHY DOWN THERE.
THE DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT THIS
LIKE THERE IS NOT AN ACTUAL
ALTERNATIVE.
>> Sean: WE HAVE TO GO.
>> IT IS INSANE.
TRIED DOING IT THAT LEGAL WAY.
IT MAKES SENSE.
>> Sean: YEAH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WE ARE PROUD OF YOU.
IT IS WELL-DESERVED AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU YOUR FIRST
SHOW, SUNDAY NIGHT, 10:00 P.M.
FILTERED CONTENT IS NEVER GOING
TO B